Williams really was America's first
individualist the first contradictory of
authority the first rebel hi I'm Nicolas
be with Reason TV and today we're
talking with John M Barrie the author
most recently of Roger Williams and the
creation of the American soul
church-state and the birth of Liberty
John Barry thanks for talking to us
a pleasure Roger Williams who was he and
why why are you writing about him
well Williams was a 17th century Puritan
minister but it was really the father of
the modern idea of Liberty and he's best
known for for religious freedom but when
I started writing the book I quickly
realized that I was not simply writing
about the emergence of the idea of
religious liberty but Liberty itself
yeah Roger Williams I mean some school
kids if they're lucky enough they learn
about him he was kicked out of the
Massachusetts Bay Colony founded
Providence eventually got a charter for
the Rhode Island wrote in favor of
religious tolerance and or actually a
secular yeah a secular government where
religion had no role to play describe
his interest in religion well as I said
he was a devout Puritan minister he was
so considered so godly that the instant
he arrived in Boston he was offered the
Ministry of the Boston Church and he
declined it because he did not think
that church was pure enough for him and
yet at the same time I mean he felt that
government had no role interjecting
itself between people and God right and
a lot of people now worry that if you if
religion and politics mix politics
suffers his basic point was that when
religion and politics or the state mix
really has to corrupt the church you
cannot possibly keep the church pure if
if the politics gets anywhere near he
had very heartfelt ideas about the
proper role of God Scripture and all of
that kind of stuff in his personal life
but he was a secularist in terms of
civil government and he also talked a
lot about limiting the power of the
state and of the
magistrates and of the Kings and all of
that where did that come from it I think
the most interesting stuff about him is
the background he was the man you Ensis
he walked around taking notes of someone
named Sir Edward Cooke very few people
have heard of but Cooke was Chief
Justice of England man who actually
ruled the house of everyone as as his
castle and and Cooke stood for English
liberty and and he's probably the single
greatest jurist in English history and
he's a guy who took on when King James
was saying you know what I driving
things like hey not so fast right they
were James's apologists who included
Francis Bacon were saying that the king
was above the law that notwithstanding
an oath he takes at his coronation he
could change any law for a reason of
state and Cooke ended up going to the
Tower of London because he said no you
talk in the book and I mean this is
interesting I mean you say two things
both of which I think are equally true
one is that we always have to be very
careful when we transpose history onto
contemporary debates and arguments but
then you also point out that John you
actually quoted King James's well I
didn't say very quite about it I use the
identical arguments right which is that
in times of extreme reason of state I
mean you had in this period you had
state-sponsored terrorism
I mean religious terrorism the Catholics
tried to assassinate King James blow up
Parliament with the King in it and even
in that context when James tried to use
arbitrary power Cooke stood up and said
no you can't do that and and the ideas
of Liberty that that Cooke articulated
ran and Williams's veins they were very
influential on his own views and his
understanding Plus James was head of the
Church of England he was personally
corrupt Williams was in personal contact
with James and with his son Charles and
he saw that corruption the idea of these
people part of the church was deeply
offensive to him so in
temporary terms now we live in a world
where in an America where there's an
ongoing war on terror that's in its
second administration and we have
president first it was Bush now it's
Obama saying look I've got special
powers now and I don't need to
necessarily consult anybody what what is
the enduring lesson of Roger Williams
that for America well I think your
nation of Laura you not use argument
which was I think outrageous he the
Constitution does not apply he you
italicized the word not in that and
that's an outrageous position of course
a constitution applies we are a nation
of laws and how did how did things end
up for Roger Williams because he
famously gets kicked out he asked the
run he's got like it's like a Lynyrd
Skynyrd song he's got two steps to the
door I think goes about to get out of to
get out of Massachusetts during a brutal
winter and he ends up in Providence but
how does this lead Providence as the
what was easily the freest society in
the world at the time he even bought
land from the India he bought land from
the Indians
the Indians saved his life when he fled
he believed in religious liberty so much
he actually convinced Cromwell to stop
Massachusetts from compelling the
Narragansett Indians to convert to
Christianity
he said forced warship stinks in God's
nostrils and he compared it to spiritual
rate he went from there as well to the
idea of a secular state because the
state he felt he understood that if the
state was going to get into religion at
all at some point in time some human had
to make a judgement about something to
do with God and he didn't think that's
the way it were so I mean Roger Williams
offers up an alternative America an
alternative America possibility one that
is based on voluntary exchange
persuasion you know kind of limited
power did it ever have a chance of
actually I mean you know if we can think
of a different world where we followed
Roger Williams rather than people who
were you know forcing Indians off the
land pushing religion into the public
square what could it have ever happened
that way right from the beginning there
were two strands that almost like the
two strands of DNA that are wrapped
around each other that have run through
American history one is sort of the best
known and probably more popular strand
where people don't like to admit it but
it does involve compulsion and and
conformity and you had this other strand
Williams really was America's first
individualist the first contradictory of
authority the first rebel and if you're
a rebel but almost by definition you're
in a minority position but that idea has
very much run through American history
it's not the dominant strand but it's
versus it is and it really I think we
can say we're both Roger Williams
admirers it energizes and it creates the
vitality in American culture I think so
Roger Williams when you start looking at
where he was at in history the role that
he played both in the English Civil War
in terms of theology in terms of civil
governance this is a guy who everybody
should know and yet he is possibly best
known for being the namesake of what has
generally regarded one of the worst law
schools in America and you know why why
did he fade so far first I think
Americans don't look much at their
history once you go back before the
Revolution I think there are very very
few figures pre-revolutionary time in
the academic community however he's
probably one of the most written about
if arguably the most written about
figure from our 17th century but he's
certainly not a household name I would
say when I started the book was funny
people would say what Roger Williams
writing about a musician and in a sense
I was actually because Roger Williams a
musician was born Lewis works and he
actually chose a name that to him
represented America and he it son accent
I chose Roger Williams it's not an
accident
one of his most successful songs is born
free well I want to thank John Berry for
talking with reason and especially for
writing Roger Williams and the creation
of the American soul church-state and
the birth of Liberty it's well worth
reading it's I mean it's an adventure
novel as well as a history of an idea
really a powerful book for reason TV I'm
Nicholas
you